[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before before this podcast
begins we are loud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him Maga wants to go to war with the
United States of America no I'm not
[__] you this what's going on Donald
at the behest of their mango musolini
Jesus their dictator their King Grandpa
sh
shitler as he was to be knowned I like
Grandpa Hitler but I kind of like
grandpa shitler I don't
know mitt ROM the yesterday forcing
Donald
Trump
to say the quiet part out loud of course
he does not want Biden to have a win of
course he does not want Republicans to
help fix the the crisis at the border
that listen there is no [__] problem
at the border other than manga going
down there and trying to fire on on
National Guardsmen trying to get
National Guardsmen to break rank that to
break the chain of command are you
[__] [__] me this is what's going
on now a lot of people are going to talk
about the scotus decision of the Razer
wire but that's set in stone that's done
that's over
with that razor wire should be removed
it can be removed it will be removed
because of chain of
command
chain of command
prevents most treason
most the Army National Guard works under
Direction in the
states under
Governors but
ultimately they are a
division of our military and when I say
our I mean the United States of
America
and when we have elections in this
country when we have elections in this
country we
elect every four years we elect a
commander-in-chief to
command that
military
now if the Republican Governors 25 of
them to be exact want to try to get
Guardsmen and guards
women to commit acts of
treason to turn their weapons towards
the United States military and the
border patrol and the federal
government
H seems kind of dangerous to me don't
you think don't you think now I know I
know it seems like oh well Tony Jesus
Christ oh my God that's like worst case
scenario is it no not really worst case
scenario there's a hell lot worse things
that could happen than a couple Bon
heads decide that they're going to be
slam in the brig and
be dishonorably discharged and Court
Marshal and gone and end up at
lenworth maybe maybe maybe maybe there's
a couple of boneh heads that will will
will even think about doing that under
the the banner of Donald Trump because
that's really that's really what they're
doing here is because the plot always
slips through their fingers and and this
is why I say messaging is so [__]
important
because honestly if months and years ago
if we would have got over this stupid
[__] feeling that people walking
across an imaginary line somehow is the
problem that is not the problem that is
not the problem that is not the problem
how we treat them and what we do when
they get
here and who we put in charge of that
effort is the [__] problem that's
that's the [__] problem see and
Republicans don't want to fix that I
mean they are the problem but they don't
want to fix that
problem because if there's no problem
how in the [__] is Donald Trump gonna be
the president of the United States how
the [__] that gonna work Jesus Christ
gasoline is damn near down 250 a gallon
unemployment's the lowest it's ever
[__] been and the stock markets as
high as it's ever
been the dark Brandon economy is on a
roll how the [__] are they going going
to sell Donald Trump to the rest of the
country as dictator for a day I just
want to taste dick just for a day day
one dick tasting all day
long how the [__] are they gonna sell
that [__] they're not [__] they can't
they can't even sell Nikki Haley to us
and she's the she's the the alternative
oh
man that [__] that [__]
delusion
that the manga cult is gonna vote for
her I got Jesus [__] Christ the
stupidity is everywhere and I love to
throw [__] democracy darts at every
single bit of it but Jesus Christ we
gotta concentrate
here and that's why I want to send you
the messaging and the narrative On the
Border today because you're going to get
you're going to get caught up in a lot
of conversations about the Supreme Court
you're going to it's going to be
inevitable here because they're the ones
that made the decision that's caused the
problem don't get in those conversations
I I reassure you I and I know you're
gonna have to fight back but I I I'm
just telling you the conversations that
you want to get
into is the messaging and the narrative
that we have overall that the
Republicans in this country are [__]
Nazis
they're [__] Nazis how else do you
explain that Grant Paul shitler is
begging begging an Army National
Guardsman who has taken an oath to their
country not to a governor you [__]
boneheads to a country to a constitution
a document an idea the
idea that this country is Sovereign and
you can't commit treason on your [__]
oath it's really simple now a lot of
these delusional boneheads believe why
it ain't treason CU Biden is dictator
and a king now he's a commanderin-chief
you [__] idiot just like every other
[__] president before him just like
your [__] musolini Jesus was for four
goddamn years
unfortunately but we have to drive this
message home that he wants to be
a king he wants to be an authoritarian
he wants to be a
dictator that is the message we must
keep driving home day after day after
day after
day [__] he's already taken away women's
rights to health care and he brags about
it he's taken away ban their privacy in
doctor's offices and [__] brags about
it he's killing women killing children
by by
by not allowing women to get actual
health care and he brags about it and
they brag about it they want to
ostracize and get rid of the lgbtq
community because it makes them feel
uncomfortable because they're closeted
or whatever [__] reason they like to
look at gay porn I don't know I don't
really give a [__] what their reason is
to want to exterminate
a Americans people who are here are
community members are neighbors [__] you
you do not get to do that and you do not
get to use our state laws or the federal
laws to do it they want to make sure
women can't vote that's what the whole
Taylor Swift [__] is about they want to
take away women's right to vote [__]
they don't even want Taylor Swift
posting on Instagram to register young
women to
vote
what's next where are they coming after
their next all of
it the entirety of American society the
American dream and the American
experiment they want it gone they want
it
done and by God if they got a stoked
some sort of war between the Texas
National Guard and and the United States
border patrol at the board fine [__] it
let let them let them have a civil war
we'll seced from the union go ahead you
[__] do it do it [__] do
it they have no
idea how the American people feel they
just don't they do not have their
thumbs on the American people's
poll and the Democrats better get around
and the media better get around and we
as a Coalition in operation go commando
better get our [__] asses around to
having this Nar and make sure that
America understands where we
stand and we stand with you ain't you
ain't gonna [__] with America no no no
you ain't doing that you ain't gonna
[__] with our Liberty you ain't GNA [__]
with our [__] freedoms you ain't
we're going to advance equity and
equality we're going to advance
diversity in this country we are going
to be welcoming to people who want to
come here and be [__] American I
don't give a [__] what their race their
Creed their religion their uality I
don't give a [__] if they want to come
here and and contribute to the American
experiment I want them
here and we need to say it one
resounding voice that any idea out
outside of of Liberty especially if it's
[__] MAA is
treasonous and is no more clear now that
this party is dead the Republican party
is [__] dead d e a d dead dead dead
[__] them [__] them [__]
them we do not need to take the shovel
out of their [__]
hands we do not Jesus Christ the
Republican National Committee was like
oh man we need to make Donald Trump the
king uh quick hurry fast and then Donald
Trump post on true social no I did I I
I'm against that I I I don't want them
to make me a king oink hink hink and
he's going to say that quiet part out
loud on stage two and I'm sure there's
going to be a tape somewhere sometime at
some point where Donald Trump has called
someone and told them on the phone hey I
want them to do what me you gonna do
what I'm King MAA I'm the king I'm the
dictator you're gonna listen to
me how do you think they got [__]
Matt gats to get rid of Kevin McCarthy
when Kevin McCarthy didn't do what the
Maga King wanted they threatened they
threatened Matt gats that they would out
him as a pedophile as if we didn't
know now Republicans are attacking him
from the other side because he got rid
of Kevin McCarthy good one Matt good one
Maddie oh you're so [__] smart aren't
you [__]
loser and they lose every time they lose
every time because of their
hatred
their hatred for what though they don't
even know anymore they don't even know
because now their hatred is against
Biden about the Border not the brown
people they forgot all about their
racism and they want their Civil
War they forgot all about the racism and
they hate [__]
Biden I want to be
treasonous I want to be a Benedict
Arnold yeah go for it
and if we're not if we're not getting
the messaging correct on this and steer
this in the direction that this is Trump
this is all Trump all of it all this
nonsense all this [__] the the he's
wasting your Governor's time your
Governor if you live in one of these 25
states there is a governor sitting at a
desk somewhere taking a phone call from
Grandpa shitler trying to [__] talk
him from committing
treason and trying to figure out a way
that he could [__] please his ass
give him [__] Cheeto dust fellacio
and not and not actually a commit
treason just appear to commit
treason [__] vile pieces of Nazi
trash that's what they are every [__]
last one of them and that's why the
Republican party is [__] dead and we
should let them die out on the [__]
limb I am sick and TI tired of this
country saving those
[__] and I'm especially tired
of liberals saving those [__] Nazi
bastards it's enough of that [__] let
them have their [__] Nazi ways let
them lean into it do it [__] see how
that works out for
you you the left finally has someone who
will [__] say the [__] that needs to
be
said there has never been anyone on the
left willing to say the [__] I'm willing
to say not a [__] one of them I don't
give a [__] you can find any of them and
they're not willing to say the [__] I'm
willing to say how I'm willing to say it
and as many times and as long as I'm
willing to pound the
drum you can you can guarantee
it put your [__] money on
it and now that we have someone now that
we have a message now that we have a
coalition that is Will willing to mock
these [__] no matter what to
save our democracy I believe we got we
got a winning Coalition that can make
these nais crawl back underneath their
[__] rocks because there ain't
nothing there ain't nothing more than
this microphone that kills
fascist because because by God these
Nazi snowflakes are are [__]
terrified terrified of a good message
for Liberty and freedom and rights and
equality and Equity why do you think
they freak out
when they hear CRT or
D let's get this
clear the roller Nazi that's right make
fun of him because he's in a wheelchair
I'm sick of that [__] too I'm sick of
that [__] people being offended that
we're [__] mocking Greg Abbot because
he's in a [__] wheelchair [__] him
[__] that roller Nazi [__] that son of a
[__] Robert wheie
it's time we get serious about how the
[__] we're going to win and not just win
elections by God but we got to win the
hearts and the minds of the American
people to know that this MAA [__] is
fundamentally 100% unamerican And it's
fascist and it's Nazi ass
[__] and it's all driven by white
Christian
nationalism this idea that somehow we
need a dictator we need a
fearer that we need a [__] King [__]
you and your stupid [__] white
Christian nationalism you can take it
and shove it up your [__] ass all day
every [__]
day and never stop
frankly we have got to stop being such
goddamn snowflakes ourselves and we have
to get on this operation go commando we
have to get these coalitions together
and we have to mock them in
unison and I'm telling you the American
people will [__] hear it and when
they do hear
it when they do hear it they will start
mocking them with us trust
me trust me there the very idea that
Trump thinks he can direct his [__]
me Team Six to go down to the border and
try to stop try to stop the United
States military and US border patrol not
only is it laughable and funny it's
fundamentally 100% un America and
[__] treason Benedict Arnold typee
[__] and and the thing is is that we
have the chain of command the chain of
command is in
place have to stop some of these things
but I bet you bet you this is what they
want then this is why Mitt Romney said
what he said yesterday now we played the
clip with the with Cliff
here and Mitt Romney called Trump so he
said Trump is the one who's calling US
senators and telling telling
them to not take this deal which you
know in all
honesty the deal ain't that great it a
it ain't it ain't that great it is
something and I and I know I I know
everyone wants to stand around and go
Tony you got to say that it's great I'm
not going to say that it's great because
it ain't that
great it ain't I mean Republicans kind
of came up with the [__] so if you think
that's great because they're calling it
a b border security bill as if the
imaginary line is the [__] problem
and that's one problem that Democrats
have that they got off that [__]
messaging they got off that messaging
and they Prov Ed messaging that would
say no we should welcome people to come
here and we should we should introduce
them into our communities grow our
communities grow the dark brand in
economy make the dark brand in economy
even [__] stronger than it is
today hell maybe we'll get gas down to
a175 a gallon maybe unemployment will go
down one more point maybe we get the
stock market up 10,000 more points huh
how about that that's optimism for you
NOP they won't do that got a point and
say oh well Republicans say it's a
problem so we we and the media believes
the Republicans every time they they say
something over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over again even though it's
lie and then they lie again and again
and again and again and they lie and
they lie and they lie and they lie and
again again again and then the media
picks it up the media says the LIE over
and over and over and over and again
again again they lie and they lie and
they
lie that's what it sounds like to me
every [__] time every on a [__]
Loop that's why that's why I'm so hard
on people like Ron Phil kowsky with
mightest touch [__] [__] that [__] I am
not going to go soft on you when you're
talking about the border is the [__]
problem that is not the imaginary line
and people crossing it is not the
[__] problem it's not and stop
dehumanizing [__] people coming here
you pieces of [__] and anyone who does
that that that dehumanizes people who
want to come here and be American is a
piece of [__]
period I don't give a [__]
anymore we got to get this [__]
messaging right we got to get the
narrative straight we got to get the
[__] facts straight and we got to
have some goddamn Humanity while we
[__] do
it so yeah you can say Democrats suck
and this bill sucks but Trump killed it
Trump killed it and he wants it killed
and the reason why he wants it killed is
because he doesn't want he doesn't want
dark Brandon going out and talking about
the dark Brandon economy and the dark
Brandon border
security because if dark Brandon gets
out there and starts tting dark Brandon
economy and the dark Brandon
border grandpa shitler loses by even
bigger he doesn't have a [__] and shine
only like chance in [__]
hell if that's the case cuz America will
buy that message the dark Brandon
economy in the dark Brandon
border I mean just imagine a dark
Brandon border woo imagine a dark
Brandon border where not not a single
not a single ounce of fentol comes
across that dark Brandon border imagine
a dark Brandon border where people who
want to come here and be part of our
communities and want to work and take
the jobs that no one else here in this
country want imagine going going to Mick
Mickey Donald's going to your fast food
restaurant or going to any restaurant or
retail store and buying Farm Goods huh
food buying food because migrants came
here and did the work that no one else
wanted to do and put that food on your
[__] plate in your belly in that
[__] golden arch
bag imagine that imagine a dark brand in
economy and a dark brand in Border that
provides prosperity and Liberty and
equity and equality for all in this
country imagine imagine dark Brandon
delivering that for
us now imagine the grandpa shitler
America where Army National Guardsman
are fighting Wars against the
dod he wants to be dictator and
King there's Legions of of rebels hiding
underground everywhere fighting a civil
war for that Liberty and that dark
Brandon economy and the dark Brandon
order that is long
gone there is no unemployment because
there is nowhere to be
employed there is no economy because the
stock market's gone there is no stock
market Donald Trump has divvied up the
entirety of the country and its wealth
to
oligarchs he's gotten what military will
follow his orders and only his
orders to execute his political rivals
to execute dissidents like me who yell
and scream at him and tell the truth and
let the American people know what the
[__] is really
up so what would you rather have huh
what would you rather have democracy or
tocy what do you want you want a
president of the United States that has
a dark branded
economy or do you want a
dictator from day
one who would take away your [__]
Liber
your rights your freedom [__] on the
Constitution tear it up make a make a
fool out of every single person that
served and fought
died that worked hard paid
taxes came here as a migrant raised
their family and their families raised
their
family and now they're integral parts of
the community communities are
beautiful widespread Beauty all across
the land and he's going to destroy every
single [__] bit of
it because he's in legal
trouble because he's got himself a cult
well it's about time we get on with this
[__] Kool-Aid
moment get on with it let's do it let's
do the [__] let's do the manga
Koolaid moment it's coming let's get on
with
it let's give them the [__] let's
give them the ingredients to mix the
Kool-Aid and let's let them guzzle that
[__] oh
yeah now's the time we get serious about
our [__] democracy in our country
because it's going to get serious Nikki
Haley ain't going to be the nominee I
don't know if you noticed but the
Republican National Committee done
signal to her that they ain't going to
let her be the [__] nominee you're
not listening to me if anyone out there
still thinks Nikki Haley somehow is
gonna win a [__] nomination you're
not paying
attention they're authoritarians they
have already turned their party into an
authoritarian party the point of project
2025 and having dictator for a day is
just that what do you think's going to
happen when the Republican parties take
o over the Executive
Branch if they get the Senate and the
house and these state governments you
think they're all of a sudden not going
to be authoritarian anymore they're not
going to suspend elections that's what
the RNC was suggesting with this is to
suspend the election suspend the results
of these elections these are people like
it's rigged it's R it's all all the
elections are rigged so go ahead and rig
up all the other ones or rig up mine too
yeah rig that one and rig that one
they're all rigged anyway just rig them
rig him for Donald Trump he's a dictator
we want him to be the king anyways [__]
it we got to get serious about this [__]
we got to get serious about this [__]
messaging we got just the weapons to do
it oh baby oh baby the [__] fam is
primed I'm telling you this is the
foundation of the pro democracy
Coalition it is the foundation of the
new liberalism in this country I know it
I can feel it I can smell it I can see
it I can hear
it this is new liberalism in this
country and we will make history I
promise you
that years to come people would talk
about this stupid little show that was
on the
internet and they did Operation go
commando and they recruited a bunch of
people and it was [__] ridiculous and
they mocked the [__] out of people and
they made fun of people and they
offended people and people were mad that
they said the f word they blew whistles
and rang cow
bells we'll
win and at the end of it when it's over
they'll [__] thank us maybe not the
way that we want them to than us but
they'll than us don't
worry that'll happen it'll it'll we'll
get there we'll get to that point we
just got to stay together we got to
concentrate on what is at hand and we
got to tell the American people what
they need to know to make the decisions
they need to make and the most important
ones In This
Moment In This
Moment
I'm so happy to have you here every
single weekday today is Friday January
26 and if you've been paying attention
January 26 is a special day here at the
fuckum fam in the Tony Michaels podcast
as soon as I'm done with the show I'm
GNA get in a car and I'm G to go to a
tattoo shop and I'm going to get my
tattoo on my arm this machine kills
fascist is the microphone tattoo it's
the microphone part of the the tattoo
it's just part they can't do it all at
once I'm going to get the Statue of
Liberty on there there's going to be all
kinds of stuff that is going to go on
this tattoo but the microphone piece is
first and I want to thank everyone
everyone who has joined team tattoo a
lot of people went to the Tony
michaels.com they click the team tattoo
fun we are so close to our goal and I am
so [__] excited I woke up so early
this morning like an hour and I couldn't
get back to sleep so just [__] it I'm
getting out of bed and I'm going and I'm
glad I did because
I was still trying to get [__] done
before the show
started we're so close to our goal let
me show it to you here let me see Let me
refresh it just to see if we've had any
sense here is here is the team tattoo
and we are so close to our goal we're
less than $40 away from our goal every
single bit of this money that goes into
the teen tattoo fund goes to the artist
all of it goes to the artist and ink
time tip it all goes to
him
and it's going to be a special tattoo
and team tattoo gets special access
here's what's going to happen bear with
me now if you're on team tattoo listen
up if you contributed to team tattoo
open those ears I'm gonna say it a few
times today so don't worry I'm gonna
remind you I'm GNA put all the
announcements of the
live of the live streams for the tattoo
on patreon okay Nate says where's the
page oh there it is where's the page
just go to the Tony Michaels and click
on team tattoo the Tony michaels.com
click on the team tattoo fund that
button
now I'm going to email everyone who has
contributed to the team tattoo fund all
33 of you at this point 33 people have
contributed so 33 people are on team
tattoo now you'll get these links for
the live streams in your email that you
use to make the the contribution so
whatever email you use used to make the
contribution is the email that it's
going to get sent to that's the only
email I got for
you it'll have all the links there'll be
all the links for the live streams are
in there my suggestion is you go click
on them and then set a notification and
what I'll do is about 15 minutes before
I go live I'll put an announcements on
patreon that we're going to go live and
then we'll go live and you guys will get
to see live images of me getting
tattooed so here's what I'm thinking the
first one will be when I get there
before I get there we'll get one while
I'm getting ready we'll get one during
the tattoo and we'll get one after the
tattoo and we got a Bonus one in there
so we might do another stream um and
also I put a bonus one in there in case
[__] goes Ary and I gotta think on my
feet and I gotta go have a stream
available and there's a link for you
guys to click
on just thinking
ahead so you'll get in your email you'll
get all these links in an email and I'm
going to send two of them after after
the show I'll send you an email and then
when I when I get close to time for the
first live stream I'm going to resend
that same email okay so if you're on
team tattoo be checking your email for
those links and then click them after
the show click them and save them and
make sure you put notifications on so
you see those I'm so excited about this
um I'm so happy you guys um you have no
idea how much this means to me and how
much I get to carry you with me every
single day on my arm and that's how I
feel about it that's why I want this
this tattoo that's why I desire to have
this permanently put on my body is
because I feel like I'm carrying every
single one of you with me so go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com all you got to do is Pan on
down and click the teen tattoo fund uh
again we're like we were $40 a second
ago um so that's all we need to reach
our goal but either way we're there
we're there and you're there and I'm
here you're here it's Friday we got the
G guy with the last name Sanchez bonee
head of the week don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
Hardon blanket I've got you covered
paron blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup
Parton blanket will protect you too
Parton blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast all right we're going to get
right into it I'm not going to do a a
grifty Griff thing today all I'm going
to say is team tattoo is on the watch
Team tattoo we've got uh
we got a couple more contributions
before we hit goals to go to the Tony
Michael back out holy
moly we just flew way over the
goal oh my God thank you so
much holy
[__] flew way over the goal you guys are
[__] insane you're [__]
insane insane in the membrane and I love
it here let me show you and we just we
just hit 856 out of 750 so
the whistles and the cowbells more
cowbell please speaking of that
yesterday we played clips of Peter
Navaro right and you couldn't really
hear
him he couldn't even [__] hear
himself it's some of the greatest Clips
I've seen in a long time that I got to
show you yesterday almost live it was
[__]
fantastic now
in in one of the videos one of the
ladies and you guys pointed out in the
chat you're like hey you need to get her
on the show you need get her on the show
it's Anarchy
princes on
Twitter I reached
out I reached
out and she said she's coming on the
[__] show that's right we're gonna
have her on the show next week we're
going to make it to her she's coming on
the show baby we're going to get on the
show and here's what we're going to do
here's here what I'm going to do I'm
going to recruit hard for her to be an
operation go commando and I want you
guys to recruit hard for her to be an
operation go commando because not not
only is she my spirit animal with the
cowbell cowbells kill fascism apparently
that machine kills
fascist the microphone the [__]
whistle a cowbell these people are
terrified no wonder no wonder they like
I need an AR-15 why I hate cowbells
they're dangerous they're loud it's a
it's
horrible but she's coming on the
show she's coming on the show and I hope
she brings her cowbell and her whistle
and her
signs because we're going to recruit her
to operation go commando here I'm dead
serious about all this I'm [__] I
know it sounds silly and [__] with the
operation go commando like I get it it
sounds [__] silly and we got some
silly art and [__] to you know to kind
of couple with it and I get it it's
talking about you know people who don't
wear their [__] underwear and [__] oh
there it is but I don't give a [__] it
might be silly but we're gonna [__]
do silly and save democracy all at the
same goddamn time that's what we're
gonna
do and we're going to do it with this
show we're GNA do it with this audience
with the [__] them
F because it is true blue here at the
[__] fam like we lost some of the
snowflakes you know what I mean we lost
some of the snowflakes a lot of them got
mad because I said certain things about
certain people well Truth Hurts don't
let the door [__] hit you where the
good Lord split you because I spoke out
against PE you're not supposed to say
bad things about them Tony I don't give
a [__] I will say almost anything
anything anything that it takes to save
this goddamn country into this
microphone almost anything I would say
that it takes and I will not [__]
stop neither I don't care if they kick
me off here kick me off there I don't
give a
[__] I don't give a
[__] speaking of cowboys
cowbells because we had yesterday we had
the we had the the the Cowboys for
democracy here's the uh here's the
Cowboys Cowboy commi
Commandos remember that it's supposed to
be cowbells but you know AI isn't always
the smartest it's not but we do have we
do have something uh for all you cowbell
levers out there I said I wasn't going
to grip but here we go granta's ice
cream shop granta ice cream shop has new
flavors the brand new flavor at
Gras is chocolate cowbell get your
chocolate cowbell flavor today at
granda's ice cream
shop it's straight from the Ice Cream
Factory in Kami Falls Missouri it's
right next to the antifa Head
headquarters there's the antifa
headquarters and the the ice cream
factories right next door where antifa
has her Factory in Kami Falls Missouri
so it's right
there again you gota [__] you gotta
have some fun while you're saving
democracy we can't make this [__]
boring goddamn if we make this boring
we'll be like every other stupid ass
with a YouTube channel on the left you
know what I'm talking about if I sat
here if I sat here and bragged about
every hund [__] subscribers that I
got you guys are like shut the [__] up
and get on with saving democracy would
you please show us some goddamn videos
that we can mock these [__] you
got it [__] let's do it now here is um
th this is oh what's her [__] name oh
yeah
Griffin Griffin she's on The View she's
a former Trump Aid she's finally coming
around to what I've been saying um since
last year when they got rid of Kevin
McCarthy let's listen
but Donald Trump is the deao Speaker of
the House Mike Johnson does not Mike
Johnson doesn't control anything he's a
puppet for man oh man it's a you know
you know what you know what could happen
you know it would be great you know be
great if the country all got on the same
page if they just [__] came here and
listen to this [__] first and then they
wouldn't have to go and [__] waste
all this time listen to all this other
[__] political [__] people
thinking they know what the [__] is up
and thinking they know they got the
pulse on America they don't
this show has it and it has it because
of you I know you think it's because of
me but this is [__] is not hard to know
if you just if you just gather up enough
people that you're not afraid to tell
them the [__] truth you'll tell them
the truth and when you tell them the
truth the truth comes out and by God
people will [__] know the truth it's
something else it really is I'm not
really doing that much I mean I mean I'm
good at this right I'm good at talking
into a microphone I'm good at
entertaining I'm good at getting you sit
here for two hours listen to [__] like
I'm good at that I admit
it but I'm not I'm not extra special at
telling to telling the truth I mean yeah
I [__] pepper it with profanity
poetry which sounds kind of cool
sometimes and we laugh and have a good
time you know but that's part of the
talent part of it it's not you're not t
it doesn't take a talent to tell the
truth it doesn't take Talent just to say
what the [__] is right in front of your
face to avoid it because oh man our
sponsors might not like that oh man I
think some of our audience members will
hate us if we say the truth I don't give
a [__] hate
me just love to hate me that's all I'm
asking um so there's Griffin getting to
the truth finally I don't know if you've
seen them speaking of whistles and stuff
killing fascist I don't know if you
heard uh Matt gats is a
pedophile I didn't mark Wayne mu said I
didn't say it I look listen when I say
people are saying I'm saying a
republican United States senator from
Oklahoma says that Matt gats is a
pedophile that's what he said he said he
showed him underage porn on the on the
house floor when he was a congressman
but this takes me back to a moment when
the people were saying that same thing
that Matt gats is a pedop they were
yelling it they were yelling it at him
and it
just tastes so good so let's listen are
you a pedophile are you a pedophile
oh [__] so scared they're terrified
terrified if he wasn't a pedophile you
I'd probably just stand there and say no
I'm I'm not a pedophile who are you but
he's not all right let's look at let's
look at all the treasonous pieces of
[__] this is going to go wild today I'm
telling you because [__] is hitting the
fan here's all the treasonous pieces of
[__] who are trying to get their their
army National Guards to break chain of
command um under the orders of Grandpa
shitler that's right grandpa shitler is
ordering these Governors to direct their
their National Guardsmen uh to com to
break the chain of command and commit
treason that's what they're that's what
that's what they're asking them to
do there is no Authority for the AR for
any any National Guard I don't even give
a [__] if it's
Texas to go down to the border and use
Force to forcibly not obey the law get
the [__] out of here with this
nonsense that's all a bunch of
horeshit I mean you talk about here I'll
show it to you on a map if you want to
see it on a map better here's a map and
if you
notice um all the these red states of
these secessionist
Governors oh boy all these Republican
secessionist yeah they're all standing
with
Texas in their treason against the
United States in their Trump Maga war
against the US OFA we hate the United
States of America [__] that United
States Constitution I mean that's what
they're
saying they're treasonous they're
Traders listen to me when I say this
it's [__]
treason it's treason okay they're not
standing with Texas they're standing
with the treasonist piece of [__]
because he doesn't want Biden to win
because he'll go to
prison and he wants to be I want to
taste sck okay I want to taste sck Tony
Tony I want to taste dick it tastes so
good I just know it on day one I'll have
it in my mouth I'll be tasting the dick
all day long he wants to be a dict
taster it's treason folks it's [__]
treason now you say Tony the chain of
command is going to prevent this which
likely yeah likely it will likely it
will it will stem the
tide of any kind of treason that throws
down between National Guardsmen and
federal
agents wild stuff that they think that
but you know okay
now I know it feels like that that's
just a wild idea and there's no way any
of this crazy stuff can happen just like
you know we look if you elect Donald
Trump it's not be big deal he's not
going to over turn they're not going to
overturn Rie Wade they're not going to
take away women's rights to health care
and criminalize pregnancies they're not
they're not going to ban their privacies
and doctr just calm
down just calm down woman just calm down
you silly woman okay calm down they're
not going to do that and they're not
going to make sure to take rights away
from the lgbtq people they're not going
to want to they're not going to want to
shoot brown people at the border because
they're brown Ronda santz oh by the way
Ronda santis can go [__] himself Ronda
santz can go [__] himself if you want
the coffee mug you can go to the Tony
michaels.com you can hit the Ted Cruz
even my dog hates Ted Cruz which is
going to be appropriate today because
I'm gonna show you a clip of that
treasonous piece of [__] too along with
Josh [__]
Holly but let's go with the people
they're trying to stoke up to commit
statas terrorism down at the border
because what they really want want is
their Ruby Ridge right they want their
Ruby
Ridge they want that moment where the
feds have to [__] kill people who are
using deadly force against people at the
border that's what they
want they want it to appear to be an act
of war against Maga so they can declare
war on the United States of America
listen to what I'm telling you listen to
what I'm telling
you these United States senators
congressmen governors of states in this
country I'm I'm not making this [__] up
[__] is right in front of your [__]
face and it's there for you to see and
if the media would just [__] say it
out loud we'd be much better off but
they won't [__] say it so I got to no
one else will [__] say it no one else
will [__] say it so I got to
Donald Trump and MAA and all the [__]
all the [__] Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets in the Senate and the house and
in these governorships these attorney
generals it doesn't matter where they
are if they're Cheeto [__] hump [__]
Cheeto humping fucknugget and that's
what they
are they want a Ruby Ridge they want the
federal government to kill MAA so they
MAA can declare war on the United States
of America listen to what I'm telling
you listen to what I'm telling you MAA
wants to go to war with the United
States of America that's what they want
that's what Trump
wants and he's Gathering up meal Team
Six to do it watch this hey Texas I have
an idea since you're no longer having to
fly illegal immigrants into these major
cities how about in the supportive
States you give us a time and an airport
port and you fly us down to you to give
you a hand I'll be on that manifest I'm
sure there's people that would be we got
your six yeah we got you we got your six
man St back and stand
by [__] fascist sheep look at these
mother this is supposed to be the
superior White
are you [__] [__] me this is the
best you got these [__] [__] are
you serious is this all that's is this
all the leftovers from January 6th is
this all you got this is like the
leftovers from January 6 you know what I
mean you know what I'm talking about
like you get sushi
right and you eat the sushi and it gives
you a you got food por from that gas
station Sushi oh my God it was
disgusting it didn't taste good you ate
most of it and gave you the shits for
days you're puking your [__] guts up
made you sick you thought you g to
[__] die and then you put that [__]
in the refrigerator you know and you
find it like four months later I don't
know about two years later three years
later the leftovers from January 6 right
and that Sushi looks like
this and you're telling me you're gonna
stick that [__] in your
mouth oh give me a [__]
break give me a [__] break with these
cousin [__] fascist get the [__] out
of here with this [__]
man I mean you know I don't want to J I
don't want to judge too hard about how
people look but I definitely want to
judge people way too hard about how they
[__]
look
right get the [__] out of here with this
[__] I mean this one guy it's like
how many American flags makes me a
patriot and this guy didn't even [__]
steam the flag he just took it out of
the package and tacked it up on his
bookshelf here with no books on it not a
single [__] book in sight well there
might be there might be how to how to
film gay porn up here I don't
know what do you want from me I don't
have a problem with gay porn I mean I'm
sure this guy this guy acts like he does
he probably acts like he has a problem
with it because he doesn't want anybody
to get you know be on to him maybe
that's why he's got the flag hanging up
there maybe maybe that's it he's got the
flag hanging up to cover up his gay porn
and he's got sitting on his bookshelf I
don't know I mean I'm assuming that if
someone's got gay porn magazines they
probably they might keep it on their
bookshelf I mean I have old I have old
porn magazines I got old playboys and
stuff with Pamela Anderson in it and
[__] and I I got him you know stacked
away somewhere but I'm sure this guy's
trying trying to hide him with his flag
you know like he's trying to hide other
[__] about himself with his
fism oh man I'm a fight
triot [__]
sheep but listen to me when I tell you
this as much as I want to mock these
people these people are dead serious
they're like hey just give me the money
for a plane ticket and I'll go down
there CU they they can't they can't
afford a plane ticket I
mean even in a Brandon economy where
unemployment's the lowest it's ever been
the stock market's as high as it's ever
been gasoline is damn near down to 250 a
gallon these [__] can't afford a
plane ticket because of corporate greed
mainly who the [__] can't afford a plane
ticket really godd
damn [__] corporate bastards
overcharging this for
[__] folks it only takes one though it
only takes one to turn us into a Ruby
Ridge moment and really honestly I don't
think it's going to get to that point I
don't think so I don't think these Le
these January 6 leftovers you know they
call them hostages but these are the
leftovers right hey Texas I have an
since you're no longer having to fly
illegal immigrant into these major
cities about supp States states you give
us a Time
airport and you fly us down to
you he don't even know he don't even
know like any cities that are close to
the border that has airports you notice
that he's like how about you uh buy us
I'm not really sure where we're going or
how we get there I hav looked at a map I
don't know what a map is really I
couldn't read it you when I had one but
folks this is serious [__] like Chris
web say says here and I I I messaged
Chris this
morning like we need to take this
[__] seriously in the message in the
narrative and he said they kept they
keep saying it so believe them Civil War
is sounding more like a promise than a
threat
they want violence they want it and the
reason why they want it is because it's
their only option it's their only option
they did have the option to fix the
problem at the border by going along
with this
bill and giv dark Brandon a win and
having a dark Brandon border and a dark
Brandon
economy but
no the
fearer grandpa shitler stood in the way
and he said no I'm the dict I'm the king
of this party I'm the authoritarian of
this party we are not a democracy here
at the Republican party we are a
dictatorship and eyes is the
dictator the head one in
charge and he said you can't do that
deal because he'll beat me and if he
beats me I go to
prison so here we
sit here we sit wait waiting for these
cousin [__] fascists to do something
at the
border as Ted
Cruz and all these other [__] boxes get
behind them here's right-wing watch this
is a guy running for [__] um a GOP
seat in state legislator of Texas his
name's Joshua ferin look at him look at
this little dick
energy I don't know how you could
project that you have a smaller dick you
know what someone take this someone take
this piece of art and put I this is
little dick energy do it right now I
know the Discord I you get I I'm sorry
we got to get this going little dick
energy for this son of a [__] and then
tag this
[__] look at
this here's what here's here's what he
says this is his post as an impending
Showdown with the federal government
scenes inevitable allow me to be the
first offer Governor wheelie my services
I added the wheelie part he's a roller
Nazi what do you want from me mock him
mock this guy for having a small dick
mock Greg Abbott for being in a goddamn
wheelchair doesn't mean you're mocking
everyone in a wheelchair that is not
what it means trust me people who are
pro democracy that are that that are
that are bound to wheelchairs understand
when you're making fun of Greg Abbott
because he's a goddamn
Nazi that you're not making fun of them
they understand it they know it they're
not stupid okay they just don't have the
use of their
legs they got the use of their brains
trust me all right they're not offended
if you [__] call out Greg Abbott for
being a goddamn
Nazi myself belong with several former
Special Forces operators I love how he
says that former Special Forces
operators the [__] that mean do they
got their Call of Duty sixpack or
something are they good Gamers boy
they're really good Shooters on that on
that shooting game well former their
special force operators on Call of Duty
6 the [__] out of here are happy to lead
an armed civilian militia to the Border
oh a civilian militia to the Border what
are you going to go kill brown people no
it's a showdown with the federal
government he says here he wants to kill
federal government agents he wants to go
to war with the US OFA folks as Texans
we must defend from enemies both foreign
and domestic I sincerely pray that
conflict can be avoided yeah I'm sure
that you do not want to get in Conflict
you [__] fat fat
[__] this guy doesn't even look like he
carried this gun down this road he's so
[__] tubby look at the cankles on
this [__] are you kidding me look at
this the guy's [__] ankles are hold
are are flying over his [__] shoes
here his jeans can't hold in his fat
calv oh Tony don't make fun of him [__]
you are you sitting me this guy's
talking about going to war with the
United States of America he's talking
about committing treason he wants to be
a you he wants to be a state rep in
Texas and you want me to go easy on him
okay all right yeah see how that works
out it ain't going to happen I'm not
going to go soft on these [__]
anymore not gonna happen I don't care
who they
are I sincerely pray that conflict can
be avoided but not at the price of
tyranny should you need us Governor we
are
[Music]
here Jesus [__] Christ
now um right-wing watch post this now
I'm guessing this is from a Facebook
page I think this is from this guy's
Facebook page so he's he's uh posting
treason as [__] as he's trying to run
for a government office on his Facebook
page and but right-wing watch rights
radical right-wing preacher current GOP
candidate for seat in the State Texas
legislature Scott
ferenstein Scott barenstein
bullshitter is what he
is is offering to lend an armed civil
militia at the border they are really
good they're really good they're really
good at Call of Duty 6 they're super
good and he's super good
at I don't know [__] beating his
children or something this is the same
guy this is the same guy at one of his
campaign events listen to what he says
no of course everyone's going to freak
out I may have people unor me after this
but this is great I'm going to say this
CPS you come to my home you will be met
with a second
amendment CPS who who in who on Earth is
it says that if CPS specifically CPS
Child Protective Services if you're not
aware now this guy's a [__] preacher
so there's one sus thing I'm I'm just
going to say it he's a [__]
Evangelical preacher so that's one sus
thing when he starts talking about child
protective services I'm like whoa whoa
Flags going up flag are going up baby
flags are going
up but if you call out CPS specifically
out of nowhere and you're like if they C
in my ass I'll [__] shoot them
because if I don't then they'll probably
all me off the jail I would someone
needs to go check on this [__] tubby
ass fucker's
kids they need to go check on
them and they need to teach this [__]
how to tuck in a goddamn shirt look at
this guy he can't even tuck in his
[__] are you [__] me you're running
for Jesus Christ learn to tuck in that
that is a that is a type of shirt that
you tuck in friend especially with a
[__] big old belly like that you tuck
that some [__] in I know you think
you're trying to hide your belly with
your [__] drapes there but that is
not how that shirt is supposed to be
worn I don't know much about fashion but
I know that you are supposed to tuck
that [__]
in come on man I guess he can't wrap it
around his cankles or something you know
what I mean I don't F [__] it Jesus
Christ these [__]
people dumber than dog turds aren't they
can't even tuck in a shirt we're
supposed to take you seriously come on
man give me a [__] break all right so
there's there's your one oh you're you
thought I was gonna give you um you I
was gonna give you video of treasonous
piece of [__] that you know all right
I'll show you something that you know oh
don't hang on hang on I'll show you
something you know I'll show you
something that's committed treason
before this [__] piece of [__]
Senator is this deal dead
effectively uh I hope so it should be if
it's not dead yet it should be dead I
mean there is absolutely no reason to
agree to policies that will just further
enable Joe Biden Joe Biden Joe B we want
to fit the border is Crisis we need to
something about this border but bad Jo B
they're terrified of dark Brandon
they're terrified of a dark Brandon
economy and they are [__] certainly
terrified of the dark Brandon
border folks this is how you brand this
[__] this is how we brand it going
forward I don't give a [__] what the
media says I don't care what the
establishment says I don't care what
these media Outlets that are in cahoots
with the establishment says I don't give
a
[__] even the even the media outlets and
some of these commentators they call
they call the mainstream media uh the
corporate media you've heard that [__]
before I know you've heard it from
someone that you know call it the
corporate media uh folks folks what do
you think what do you think some of that
[__] media that is Independent Media
independent they're in cahoots with the
establishment what do you think they are
what do you think what do you think that
is why do you think I am independent the
way that I'm independent huh that's
because no one can tell me what the [__]
to say and what not to say FU [__] her
[__] him you know what I mean you know
what I
mean and [__] this guy want to kill the
bill good they're saying the quiet part
out loud Mitt Romney made him do it I
guess in the service of his country
that's one one good thing that he did
and it's not just him it's Todd young
too but no one knows who the [__] Todd
young is let's listen I think James
langford's been working uh very hard to
secure the southern border uh to give
the next president whomever it is uh
more Authority so that we can SEC secure
the southern border so anything that
interrupts that
negotiation uh I think would be tragic I
hope no one is is trying toh take this
away for campaign purposes do you think
this is what he wants the issue Donald
Trump this is why he's doing I think I
think the border is a very important
issue for Donald Trump uh and the fact
that he would communicate to uh
Republican Senators and Congress people
that he doesn't want us to solve the
Border problem because he wants to blame
uh Biden for it is uh is really
appalling now I'm no friend of Mitt
Romney and I don't know if this guy is
either he might be I don't know he might
be um but it's Friday and you know what
that means guy with the last name Sanz
is with us Gabe Sanchez welcome welcome
how are you my friend good good good
good good good so um I don't know if
you're a friend of Mitt Romney But Mitt
Romney I'm not a friend of Mitt Romney
and I don't like to say this out loud so
don't tell anyone I said this okay you
cannot you got a promise got promise you
not this is just between you and me okay
good y' no one else is here hit mute hit
mute for just a few seconds while I talk
privately to Gabe Sanchez here Mitt
Romney is really politically smart here
on this one and the reason why heally
smart is and because of some of the
evidence that I seen this morning is
because what Mitt Romney knows is Mitt
Romney needs to get Donald Trump on
camera saying I don't want this bill
because I don't want Joe Biden to have a
win and then it's exactly what Donald
Trump is going to say and Mitt Romney
knows it Mitt Romney Mitt Romney knows
Donald Trump is one of the easiest
people to bait in in all of political
history like he's the easyest and and we
also know that Donald yes incred I mean
just look at today right and yesterday I
mean like look at these look at his
interactions that he has in the
courtroom look at the short temper that
Donald Trump has when somebody says that
no the [__] that you're saying right now
has already been proven to be true in
the sense that you raped in a Caroll so
you saying that she's lying is in fact
lying about what already happened it was
decided judge cap was like look we're
gonna establish some truths here and
that truth is that Donald Trump is
already liable he's already liable for
saying these things is this like truth
like he post on TR social or is this
like actual truth this is the truth this
is this is the actual this is the golden
truth I just want to make sure Kaplan
saying look we've already gone through
this and eing Carol has been proven uh
in that she was raped and that Donald
Trump defamed her and he's liable and uh
we're not we're not going to re we're
not we're not going to uh try to
disprove what's already been proven in
the court and so each time along the way
Donald Trump has tried to say or Alina
Hava I I swear to God like I don't know
how she got her law degree man it is not
that hard it is not that hard to bew you
know maybe she was given a little
helping
hand you know maybe maybe to someone who
was issuing the bar exam but what I will
say is
that Donald Trump and alen H but Donald
Trump especially is incredibly easy
debate and to your point about Mitt
Romney you know he's on the way out and
he's like look man if there's anything
I'm going to do I'm going to make sure
to blow up this this [__] clown show
of fascists by exposing them for who
they are we've made well but I I think
he's doing more more than he's doing
that I think what he's doing is he's
making sure to lay the blame at the feet
of the person who is responsible for
this and it is one person the one person
responsible for all this [__] chaos
everywhere and anywhere is [__]
Donald Trump there is not a problem at
at the border there is not a problem at
the border with migrants coming into
this country across the imaginary line
that want to be here it is how we treat
them and what we do with them when we
get here and what our policies are once
they get here and then how easily it is
for them to get here legally or
illegally however you want to say it if
that's that that's the language they
want to use fine [__] them right but
here's the thing is that this is all
caused because the Republican party is
already an authoritarian party they are
Nazis there is no turning back back this
party is dead I mean listen dead take
Cruz listen to him uh you have blasted
it obviously and now there's this other
reporting coming out suggesting that
maybe the uh Mitch McConnell and and you
know leadership is pulling back their
support for it what is going on there
are Republicans really going to back
away from an issue that they keep saying
needs to be solved so let me break that
into two pieces you you started by what
Biden is saying and I'll tell you what
Biden is saying on that there's a
technical term for that that's called a
lie and it's not just a little bit of a
lie it is a brazen it is the definition
of kah here's why when Joe Biden became
president he inherited the lowest rate
of illegal immigration in 45 years he
inherited great success and he
deliberately broke the Border he opened
up the Border three decisions caused
this crisis his first week in office Joe
Biden halted construction of the border
wall he reinstated Catch and Release and
he pulled out of the incredibly
successful remain in Mexico agreement
and those decisions caused illegal
immigration to Skyrock another reason
okay now now here's the thing uh um Gabe
Sanchez yes is that all those things
were true about the prior Administration
and they weren't going to go to Civil
War they weren't going to [__] uh
kill AR armed armed National Guards or
borders men I mean really because that's
what that's what MAA is doing here is
they're stoking January six again at the
border where they they violence yeah
it's gonna it's gonna lead
Abbott from the safety of his goddamn
wheelchair is going to cause violence
you're not supposed to make fun you're
not supp to make fun of the roller na
that's right don't give a [__] that's
right when you have people when you have
people who are incredibly racist
xenophobic bigoted hateful vile
disgusting people that want nothing and
keep in mind these are the Republicans
who say oh we have Christian values we
love people we love people Jesus Christ
we love him he housed people he clothed
people he washed people he fed people
and what are you doing you're putting
razor wire in a in a body of water where
people are crossing over who are seeking
Asylum and trying to see a find
themselves a better opportunity give me
a [__] [__] you know what no no it's
just like I hate it I hate it I hate it
there are very few things in life that I
[__] hate and this is one of them
maybe because I come from like I'm part
of the Latino community and I have that
background and my father not that he
crossed the Rio Grand like that but that
my father came to this country seeking
better opportunities so that he could
provide money back to his family in
Mexico when I see this type of [__] it
[__] hurts me deep
inside where I see people that I don't
even know but I associate with
culturally even if they're not from the
same country that my family comes from
and the idea that somebody like Greg
Abbott who's now seeking the the
approval of 25 other state governors in
other states that do do not border the
state the the the country of Mexico that
have never had this issue that are okay
with people sending them on buses in
Plains to cold areas the freezing
[__] frigid cold during the holidays
when oh my God this is supposed to be a
time of love and prosperity and family
and and Community oh man you know Jesus
Christ he Our Savior was born on this
day even though he wasn't he was born
during the
summertime anyway uh uh but the idea
that we have facts it's just the idea
that we have these [__] people that
are okay look at Ted Cruz come and take
it shut the [__] up you [__] ass [__]
the idea that you were GNA put barb wire
or razor wire in a graphic and say come
and get it like you're some wise ass
tough guy it pisses me off to a degree
that I that I I
just some okay look I'm just gonna say
I'll just say this Ted Cruz has a face
that's somebody would punch okay and and
I'm sure that somebody will do it at
some point in time and for the FBI agent
that's watching the show I'm just joking
it's just a
joke well here here may maybe maybe we
can give them a good image of uh the uh
the the punchable face that you were
talking about maybe that's a oh is that
the thing where he was like he's like
liberals don't understand
comedy this is comedy I mean this is
this is funny but didn't he I I think I
when I was looking at his uh his feet
last night because I was like oh you
were looking at his feet his yeah his
feet I don't know if you know this but
Ronda santis like a lot of people are
into like only fans can go [__] himself
yeah yeah no Ronda santis can't go [__]
himself he can go [__] himself uh the
irony of calling his dog Snowflake and
then abandon his dog during a snowstorm
is forever forever comedic but you have
you have this photo of him where I think
he was quote tweeting and it was
something with the Babylon be it was
something about mutton chops and then
he's like liberals don't get comedy and
it's like I don't I don't get I don't
get what you're getting like it's not
that nobody finds it funny but I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell you something actually
this beard here that he has this fake
beard that he has in this Photoshop
picture is way better than his beard he
has this is a way better this is a way
better beard way better the one he's got
his total [__] trust me coming from a
guy who has a who has a I have a
spectacular my beard I don't I just
like is spectacular G
gr go back to the video real quick I
just want to point something out the
video or this no the video I just want
the video well [__] I I was hoping you'd
go back to that okay what no no no no
we'll go back there but go back to the
video and go to the part where it's a
closeup of him
okay right there now okay look okay if
we look at that's a pretty good if we
look at this guy's hair which by the way
the stress and anxiety of his job has
caused him to age excessively poorly but
when you look at his hair it reminds me
like it almost looks fake in the way of
we're like all right we have this person
they're in a film or they're on stage
they're doing a performance and we need
to age them up so let's put some white
paint or some gray paint in the hair to
touch it up to make them look older than
they are like it looks fake it looks
like the fake snow that you put on a
Christmas tree during the holidays
that's the type of [__] and I'm sure off
like Dand dff too but that's what when I
look at Ted Cruz I'm sure that's not the
only thing that flakes off of him I'm
just saying I mean like this guy he
can't dribble a ball he doesn't know
what he's talking about and every chance
he gets I'm actually surprised that in
this interview because there's another
interview I saw this week where he he
promotes his podcast to an a degree that
I I just don't understand speaking of
promotion I go to
the.com you get even my cat hates Ted
Cruz and even my dog hates Ted Cruz it's
going to be cold in Texas I'm sure so
grab your even my dog ain't speaking of
grips and
promotion listen I've got a podcast too
and this podcast that I got it podcasts
all the time I it podcast so much that
it forces me to say the word podcast
more than I even want to podcast and
when I do podcast I say podcast and when
I go out in the world and I say podcast
and then when I'm on camera I gotta say
podcast podcast podcast because I've got
a podcast gab did you know I have a
podcast did you know I have a podcast I
think I knew you had a podcast all right
well I'm just just checking to see if
you knew all right on this podcast on
Fridays we do Bon of the week let's get
to it let's not waste any time let's not
Buck around let's just go right to this
boom bone end of the week bone Ed of the
week let's get to
[Music]
[Applause]
it all right Gabe Sanchez we have some
obvious candidates for bonee head of the
week and we could add so many more I'm
sure and I know we have a DM and an
alpha cuck and we got some great of the
DM but let's get right into it Matt gats
is a pedophile that's the reason why
he's on here I'm sure is that is that
ped alert pedal
alert am I right is that what look Matt
gate should stay what happened what
happened do you know the story do you
know what that I I missed it I've had my
attention on other F the story it was it
was reported by Daily Beast um and The
Daily Beast said that
that basically the the reason that Kevin
McCarthy got ousted was because he
continued to allow the Ethics Committee
to investigate Matt Gates now if we
remember if we remember for 30 months
the doj was investigating Matt Gates and
they ultimately said we're not going to
pursue though something to keep in mind
though is they said we decided not to
pursue they never said the case was
closed so there's this question mark as
to whether the case case was still open
and not officially closed so on the
Ethics Committee which which open uh you
know under the I guess guidance we'll
say of Kevin McCarthy uh opened up Matt
Gates was like okay this is my chance
and then used the budget resolution as
an opportunity to wedge his way in and
say guys we can't trust him we can't
trust him he's not getting the job done
as a way to because Kevin McCarthy told
Matt Gates I don't have control over the
Ethics Committee Matt Gates didn't
believe that so he said guys we got to
oust him we got to get rid of him if we
get rid of him we'll get rid of the eth
Ethics Committee investigation which you
[__] idiot no it won't it's almost
like they're an independent group like
they're all it's it's it's almost like
they exist to be neutral to avoid any
Party politics and avoid anyone from
meddling in their Affairs as as they go
in through this it's almost like they
got to be ethical right yeah it's crazy
it's crazy one one time piece makes a
good point here and we need to bring
this word back more because pedophile is
kind of overused I think chomo chomo is
like the Prison Talk did you know that
chomo I I knew that you know what chomo
is no Cho's child moner chomo that's
that's what they call that's they call
pedophiles and yeah and and as we know
they don't last very long in jail like
prison there's one if there was ever one
like rule of of that it's the that those
people
chomos don't last very long because it's
like we got murderers and it's like
you're wait you you touch a child you do
anything to a kid you're you are the
bottom of the barrel dud you be a
[__] serial killer and kill hundreds
of people and you're not a Cho you know
I mean you could be but you're you might
not be yeah Matt Gates I mean those
things are coming back up we have to
remember that uh Ginger
lucky his wife now MH her sister came
out I think in 20 21 when this all came
when this first was brewing up and she
came for and was like oh yeah Matt Gates
made some very like sexual perverted
advances to I think her she said her
friend and then she talked about her
experience this dude dude's a guy he's a
creep all around man yeah well watch I I
played this video earlier but this is
some of the best footage of someone
asking mats if he's a pedophile are you
a pedophile are you a pedophile are you
a pedophile
oh I love it you know what's funny about
this
moment this this is shortly after like
30 seconds after Matt Gates and margar
Taylor green and I'm trying to remember
who else was there but they had a press
conference and M marger Taylor green
literally said because I made I made
Never Back Down jokes about it again a
tip for anyone out there if you're going
to make a slogan or your motto never
Never back down for a political campaign
at some point you're going to have to
back down whether you quit done or
whatever please Never Surrender Never
Surrender Never Back Down you end up
doing that thing and it makes you look
like a fool so here if you're on the if
you're on the Democratic side do not do
that but if you're on the Republican
side keep doing that please so In This
Moment Margie Taylor green said she's
like we are never going to back down
whistle comes in they back down because
fascists hate whistles did you say
whistle did you say whistle and I don't
normally do this but we're going to skip
to the DM because I want to show some
whistle I got some great news gab
Sanchez I don't I don't know if you know
this the whistle
ladyy princess she's gonna be on the
show next week no she is yes she is
she's she she's a big fan of the Tony
Michaels I couldn't and tell you why
probably but
um it's almost like it's it's almost
like
microphones whistles and cowbells have a
lot in common they they like to kill
fascist um um so tell us about the Peter
Naro as I pull up these C petar
hilarious my my my buddy with the rolled
up sleeves like a like a college
basketball coach look we're going to do
Green Bay Packer style the footballs and
the balls and the footballs we got the
Green Bay it's a sweep it's a sweep
footballs in the quarters quarters backs
uh Peter
Navaro ended up getting sentenced to
four months in prison which is not long
enough but still
still four months is better than no
months I guess but it goes to show you
that if you ever affiliate yourself with
Donald Trump if you ever put yourself in
a position of backing the big lie and
believing that Donald Trump won the 20
20 election and that Joe Biden didn't
win and [__] [__] slapped him across
the
country then you're gonna find yourself
in prison you're gonna find yourself
with a felony you're gonna find yourself
being in charge of paying $148 million
for defaming people it just doesn't it
doesn't play out well for you if you
around and find out it's like that you
know more you [__] around the more you
find out the Republican party I think
they need I don't even know what their
slogan is other than you know the grand
old pedophiles but
but the way that their name is I think
it should be fafo right like it should
be [__] around find out that should be
the tagline of their party because
they're the ones who lean into that the
most it's true they they they are
finding out like it takes time and Tony
and I talked about this before because
there are a lot of people were like
merri Garland isn't doing this merri
Garland isn't doing that we said there
are so many things that are cooking
right now you cannot have him go okay we
we're just going to blindly go after all
these one fascist that they're trying to
cook they're trying to cook a whole
party of [__] na you know what I mean
this is like if anyone if anyone watch
the the if anyone watches the bear
season two the Christmas episode where
Jam Lee Curtis is cooking all of that
[__] in the kitchen that's basically
what's happening with the doj little bit
time all these people who tried to
overturn the government or overthrow the
government overturn the results of the
2020 election tried to install fascist
people in office tried to keep them try
to not leave all of this stuff you have
the doj cooking cooking in a kitchen for
for a party of like 50 people and
they're trying to manage everything so a
lot of people I remember this
specifically like he's not working fast
enough he's not working fast enough
listen they're cook listen right now
they're cooking faster than a meth head
in the trailer park okay all right it's
what they're doing here's Peter Naro
yesterday watch back here this attorney
I want to show this video because we
showed a bunch of them yesterday but
watch is this attorney assaults
assaults Anarchy princes watch this so
I'm gonna do is say a few words and I'm
gonna have several These Fine attorneys
behind me say a few words but the top
line here is
[Music]
that yeah the top line here is that U
Woodward more cowb please cowb more cowb
more Cowell first impr more get it get
that
yeah for the Supreme Court it is a case
that really asks the important
question of whether a senior White House
Aid and Alter Ego or the
president can be compelled
to more more C more of it more of it we
need more is where we're at
unfortunately unfortunately I can't
think when there's all these and
whistles I can't think I got a fever and
the only prescription is more
cowbell I got give me more cowbell give
me I got a fever is fascism and the only
prescription the only cure is more
cowbell get more cowbell please
wow oh baby oh that cowbell please there
she is doing her thing uh Anarchy
princess I mean it's amazing how how
just a
cowbell and a whistle can
trigger fascists and these people come
out swinging to be like oh we're so
tough all you lib turds all you guys
going to cry these snowflake tears and
it's like all it took was a [__]
whistle a whistle that that probably
cost like less than a dollar a cowbell
that cost maybe like $150 on Amazon well
and a white P poster board with some
marker on it look how you suzer he
assaults her see here on camera he's
assaulting her you can't do that you
can't you can't touch someone I tell you
what man I that's why I wouldn't want to
be SP in spitting distance I give her a
lot of props because I wouldn't want to
be in within spitting distance of these
son [__] for obvious reasons but if
they ever touch me like that dude oh my
God because most States once someone
touches you that [__] is on like Donkey
Kong you touch me [__] you touch me I'm
totally gonna defend myself
yeah you encroached my space you touched
me the barrier has been broken right
let's brawl shit's shit's gonna I would
love I would love to see a moment of
like getting touched and then there like
you just catch it like
just across just the best Nazi punch
ever oh yeah just the best one ever oh
my God all right so that's that was
Peter Navaro uh in his little DM doable
mention Peter
Naro cowbell love
it um speaking
of people who are probably not immune
from the cowbell sound Alina habba Alina
habba she was also dingdong
that's a great one ram a damama dingdong
and have a slab a dingdong she loves
she's got she got I said in your show
because you had a show last night and I
came she does she does got she's got
great dsls well you know when when you
pay enough money I guess you could you
get yourself anything so why I mean it's
not her it's is it her dsls that made
her end up on the
uh on the it's clearly not her legal
expertise Tony oh okay does she have
legal expertise at all does she have
remember and I'm sure you're going to
play this right now when ask the
question would she rather want to be
pretty or her have looks versus smarts
and she was like oh easy I'd rather be
pretty I can fake being smart no you
can't [__] no you can't we clearly know
in the transcripts on camera in other
interviews you don't know what you're
doing is this is this is this the clip
this is the clip this is the peanut
butter dick podcast I don't know maybe
maybe those dsls like a peanut butter
taste dick I don't know I don't know
peanut butter peanut butter podcast all
right let's listen to her on the peanut
butter podcast let's listen somebody
said to me Alina would you rather be um
would you rather be smart or
pretty what now first off no one said
this no no one actually no no one no one
said that no one this is Alex can I get
can I get things that never happen for
500 that's just not a thing that
happened mean if you there's um I think
it was it can be applied to men too but
I think at at the point when it was made
um it was like look women you date and I
don't believe this but women you date
can either be two of three things right
yeah they can be
smart
pretty and crazy yeah but you can only
have two of those things right so she's
either smart why can't I have three I
want all three I'm not saying you can't
have all three I'm just saying this one
person I might I might want a crazy
[__] I'm not saying I agree with that
I'm just saying crazy lunatics you
think maybe they have dsls like this I
don't know who knows when when she
brought that up and said oh it was
either this or this it reminded me of
this I think it was a standup bit or a
joke that a comedian made and he's like
look women can only be two or three
again I don't believe that but that was
when she makes that St I'm like this
sounds like you're taking there's
anything wrong with that not that
there's anything wrong with that I love
I love how you're going with the
Seinfeld um disclosure not that there's
anything wrong with it I don't believe
that I want to point out these are not
my opinions but when she says it it
reminds me of that joke oh boy um the
laboratory is pointing something out
here in the background they said the U
the signed lockers are just like the
bang bus I don't know what the bang do
you know what the bang bus is I know
what the bang Buzz is I don't know what
is the bang Buzz Tony I don't know I
don't know let's talk about her DSL porn
counter let's talk about her DSL though
let's go and I said oh easy pretty I can
fake being
smart but I meet him all the time
Alena you know I mean that's the honest
truth and it's gonna make me you know
I'm sure there'll be some Washington
Post article about it tomorrow Daily
Beast my favorite but listen like you
have to be honest it doesn't hurt to be
good-looking in
oh wow okay that might be the truest
thing she said it doesn't hurt to be
good-look yes goodlook people are able
to get things that other people aren't
able to exactly me look at Tony Michaels
he doesn't have anything podcast I got
this podcast and
I he a got [__] you ugly
[__] but it's just funny because
it's like she's like oh I'm sure the
Washington Post and the daily you know
what they probably will because they're
going to bring up your record and
they're going to bring up the things
that you've done in court that are just
facts on how you presented cases I mean
here's I just have to ask has she ever
tried a case I don't know because the
way that I watch her with Trump I'm just
like I just don't know if you've ever
taken it into actual practice before has
she
ever tried a case that's a good question
for an attorney now here's thing a lot
some people some people many people are
asking for the Alina Haba uh before
surgery pick like people are like hey
wait do you how does she look before
after what you talking about well I mean
I mean uh money can make you
good-looking money can buy you to a
degree they they they posted a picture
of her like in a in a swimsuit but I
think it was at marago at the swimming
pool and they're like eat your heart out
I'm like what the [__] listen she's she
looks like she can suck a mean dick she
really does she looks like she can't
what what do you want from me what I
mean no know look I just I just as a
person who would normally like like the
feeling of you
know what what I'm just being honest
you're just telling the truth as a
person who would like getting their dick
sucked I'm just saying that it is
possible that she looks like she could
suck a mean one I mean it's a it's a
good possibility but what I'm saying
though is what is what is that honestly
she's admitting that she's dumber than
dog [__] when she says I'm pretty I'm
pretty I'm pretty she's she's admitting
to the fact she's like look I bought
these looks and she didn't always look
like this this is what she looked like
this is what she like
previously with enough
filler injections plastic surgery which
hey it's like dude man get all the
gender affirming care and surgery and
procedures that you want and now I I
gotta point out I gotta point out here
really quick quick she bought these dsls
these are not natural these here are not
natural
dsls the these here these are not
natural she bought a lot of the looks
which I mean I'm if you want to buy it
you want to yeah sure no problem totally
fine you can to you know I have nothing
against you you know improving or
modifying was bad looking before I mean
she's a little homely but not that much
I mean not that much so I understand
that she you know paid good money to
look like this but listen Alina I know
you paid good money for your for your
fake ass degree or your your your
credentials that you're smart and your
and your dsls but it's not working on
anyone it really it really you know that
she has three kids I didn't even know
that I saw I saw Jay uh posted that she
had three kids and I had to look it up
turns out she actually is a mother which
another person it's like another set of
kids that I feel sorry for no [__] well
speaking of people who hate children uh
there's uh there's the roller Nazi and
Governor Greg Abbott U oh wait no wait I
want to go back the other guy from Texas
[__] this guy from Texas
justor which we kind of already covered
but basically it was around the Border
it was related to
Greg this this [__] idiot trying to
come in and saying come and take it with
Barb Wire which is let me let me show
you that post because I think that's a I
think that's a good point I I need to
show people that it's disgusting and
insane to see how a socalled Christian
can look at innocent mothers and
children crossing the border getting
tangled dying drowning from razor
wire and say come and take it I don't
know if you've seen like not only it's
like you have razor wire on the along
the bank of the river but I don't know
if you've seen it it looks like a like
there's a bunch of trash that's caught
up it just like it looks very bad like
presentation wide aesthetically it looks
like [__] it looks like trash they are
making the Border look like [__] it
makes us look like a [__] old country
makes us look like a [__] Old Country
they're okay they're like look come and
take it we're we're totally fine with
killing people well here's what I said I
said treasonous piece of [__] trash I
don't know you can try to find the LIE
there if you want tell me tell me where
there's a lie in that statement thisy
F trash with and he's defending this the
idea
that that people are to you know what if
we l if we lose some people that are
some illegals that's totally
fine well I mean also he's also saying
that he wants he wants to shoot and kill
border agents because border agents are
the ones that are going to take this
razor wire down yeah he wants to shoot
and kill because he got to come and take
it now use my second amendment on you
you [__] and that's like the that's
the sentiment
right another another job you know when
people are like oh man these you know
these law enforcement agents aren't
patriotic two positions where I would
say these are pretty patriotic jobs
would be defending the capital and
defending the border right those are
like pretty high up there when it's like
I did my patriotic Duty and I served my
country by securing it there's nothing
more patrio than that and the fact that
Republicans like Ted Cruz and all these
other uh America first uh you
know
Nazis are willing to go out and say
we're going to kill those people or
those people should go kill themselves
because they didn't do the thing that we
wanted them to do and this is mind you
this is after the fact Joe Biden was
like look man if you guys give me a bill
I'll sign it give me a [__] bill put
it on my desk I will sign it I will give
you the funding I will give you the
people I will give you the technology I
will give you the resources I will give
you everything you need to help create a
better solution and Republicans are like
no whoa hey we can't do that we can't do
that no no no and to the earlier point
about Mitt Romney it's why he's trying
to bait and trap uh Donald Trump he
needs Donald Trump to say it out loud
you know as just like Donald Trump was
like I was the person who overturned Ro
v Wade you did it for you tried to do it
for 50 years and you guys couldn't do it
until I got here I took your [__]
Healthcare I criminalized pregnancies I
banned your privacy and your doctor's
offer it was me that did that H what are
you gonna do about it we're GNA vote
against you you [__] idiot speaking
of voting against people now why do not
the people Texas vote against this
stupid
[__] the best one I seen this morning
was Robert wheie Robert
Willie Robert
Willie he's a confederate general Robert
wheelie I I I can't tell you that people
are like hey stop making fun of him he's
in a wheel I I've GNA make fun of him no
matter
what me do you know the story behind
that what's that wheelchair accident
right he gets by a tree the tree was
like I'll just take the bottom half this
like a Madison caor thing because I see
wheelchairs they not he's not it wasn't
because he was like punching a tree like
I'll get back that would be hilarious
wouldn't that be funny come on man that
would be [__]
hilarious a tree and then the other
trees were like [__] you but wait but
that but that would mean that he wasn't
in and then Madison goth was like trying
to recreate I don't know yeah that's
some wild you know stuff mixes in if you
remember the reason Madison cauthorne is
in a wheelchair and is paralyzed from
the waist down is because he was driving
a truck with his friends and they were
swapping in and out in and out the like
[__] because they liked I know he
likes to [__] his cousin I don't know
what they were I don't know where fck
cousin humping fist I don't know where
the hands were I know that he loves to
you know dry hump a a cousin or
two uh but what I will say is that if
you look at what happened there's
a they're almost the cause of their own
problems you know well I
mean was if he didn't do the things he
did in that car whatever they may be I
don't know
right but uh this is another one where
you look at Greg
Abbott and the idea that people are like
oh don't make fun of him it's like this
guy is one of the worst terrible people
we have in a in a [__] law making uh
law making position hold my beer then
because here's Governor [__] Governor
skit face up in Oklahoma and just see
what he says too huh is Oklahoma On the
Border well you know the border of the
the the fascist Republic of Texas
let's I mean what what do you want for
me what do you want for me wondering
like is is Oklahoma On the Border like
like Florida's On the Border well I mean
you know it's kind of closer okay okay
okay but but they both Ronda santis
Ronda santz who by the way can go [__]
himself Ronda santz can go [__] himself
um Rhonda santz and Governor everyone
everyone tell me that Oklahoma is not a
border I know it's
not it's a joke I was saying for the
same reason that Florida is because you
dumb son of a [__] good Lord where did
you go to school did you go to school in
Oklahoma there sunny all right let's
let's see if Governor skead went to uh
School in Oklahoma let's see if he knows
the definition of treason especially
this this host to see if they know the
ver like the definition of it there's
Rumblings that Joe Biden should or may
actually federalize the National Guard
take that power away from Greg Abbott
let's say this showdown I mean okay
first off the National Guard is
federalized I don't know if this guy
knows that or not the National Guard is
federalized now they give the National
Guard as as a as a the ability for
Governors to to have the ability to to
deploy people in I don't know like
emergencies and wait wait are you
telling me hold on hold on hold on hold
on okay this is this kind of reminds me
of this like presidential immunity thing
okay so if you have a a a word
phrase okay guard National Guard okay so
National National National would be one
National National would be would be
Federal right States states rats States
rats National naal listen states have
states have National rights okay so but
um also if know anything about National
Guards they can also be deployed by the
um what's that guy called that was
elected um in 2020 is they like to call
him Brandon H I think they can be
deployed because he's a commander-in
chief yeah dark Brandon um dark Brandon
but here is here's C Governor stie head
let's see what he says about treason let
me back it up let's see there's
Rumblings that Joe Biden should or
actually federalize the National Guard
take that power away from I got it let's
say this showdown I mean this that's
what it is it's a show it's a showdown
Gabe Sanchez it's a showdown excuse me
excuse me welcome welcome to the Friday
Showdown okay coming to the Border
coming to a border near you up in
Oklahoma okay the Border those illegal
they're coming across the r
Grand the Rio the Rio Oklahoma okay
let's let's listen to what he says he's
going to get to the treason part here of
power and loyalty and consti what it's a
showdown it's a showdown power and
loyalties and constitutionality let's
say oh it's again a loyalty to the
Constitution it's almost like it's
almost like the national guard takes an
oath to a document and that document
might have a name H I wonder what the
name of it is I wonder if he said any of
the words that seems similar to the name
of that document and what is what what
it's a showdown to so he's basically
saying that the the national guards in
the state are in a showdown against the
Constitution which they declare an oath
to let's keep going see if we can spot
the treason this part he does that how
many people say no you know what screw
you Biden Administration and how many
people stay in fight with Texas versus
the federal things and does that put us
on course for a force onforce conflict
Oh you mean
treeson yeah this is listen listen I
want everyone to know I listen to me
very closely if there is any national
that do what this [__] bonehead just
said they will be sent immediately to
the brg they will be stripped of all
their [__] rights they will be
imprisoned and they will likely see a
court Marshal and possible [__]
charges and they will go to lenworth and
trust me I've been to lenworth not that
prison but I've been to lenworth and you
do not want to go to lenworth the town
sucks it's a [__] town it's a prison
town There's prisons everywhere it's
really
Dreadful Kansas beautiful state Lev
worth is a shitty City anyways any who
you do not want to go to Le and you
don't want to go to the military prison
for
treason treason you [__] bonehead but
listen to what the Governor of Oklahoma
says about treason listen to his word
that he uses to describe this type of
treason Gabe
Sanchez I mean right right now you've
got the federal agents that are cutting
the wire and then you've got the Texas
National Guard on orders to put up wire
I mean this is a this is a
counter a powder keg worth of tension so
it's very uh it it's it's a very weird
situation we certainly stand with with
Texas on their right to defend
themselves what but Biden's going to be
in a tough situation so in other words
he's going to try to federalize these
troops in other words put them on
federal orders and so now their
allegiance technically goes to the
president United States
governor and of course I think a lot of
Texans these are still um they're still
Texans that are weaken uh you know
they're in National Guards they do look
at this look at how shitty it looks now
well so so he's getting to the he's like
describing treason he's like look so
what Joe Biden's gonna do is he's gonna
use the authority that he has as a
commander-in-chief let's go Brandon to
to to federalize federal troops in this
effort to make sure that federal troops
aren't preventing Federal officers from
doing their Duty which he has right I
don't want to say Tony I don't want to
say that if the tables were
turned don't want to I look I don't want
to say it but I'm going to say it if the
tables were turned and there was a
certain somebody Trump and he got his
way and he said hey you're not doing the
thing that I want you to do I'm GNA send
in the National Guard to do this thing
and enforce it and you'd be like whoa
whoa hold on wait that's that's a
federal federalizing yeah you're what
you doing dude what what are
you I mean it's it's almost like he said
that it's almost like he said that out
loud probably it's almost oh man it's
crazy Tony who sent in the National
Guard during Co God who was that who was
who sent the National Guard to enforce a
curfew during there a president was
there a president during 2020 or is it
was was it a dictor was it a dict it's
almost like look it's almost like states
are like oh look there's uh there's
violence committed by white supremacist
and there's damage and vandalism and we
need to send in a curfew during this
time okay look it's almost like a state
like a governor may have requested it
right like they put in a request and
then and then it was issued right like
they didn't just say hey it's a state we
can we can do whatever we want duck Gabe
Trump did Oklahoma is not on the border
either okay yeah I'm so dumb to Gina
thank you Regina um here's the thing
here's the thing is Governor stit here
let's listen to the word he uses to
describe treason because it's
interesting how he describes treason
listen called up on duties by the
governor and think they would be in a
difficult situation to protect their
Homeland or treas follow what Biden's
saying open very interesting but then
you know then you it's very interesting
treason treason is very interesting well
it's interesting it is very it's very
interesting when you try to legally uh
run around the the actual facts here the
other thing I really want to point out
and I'm going to do a what was that on
this because
well Gavin Newsome did a [__] master
class on MSN you want to see that you
want to see that clip yeah yeah I think
we should that keep keep keep the one
thing that I'll say about this and the
reason one of the biggest reasons that
this really this whole conversation
pisses me off in the way that
Republicans are talking about it is
because they keep calling it a [__]
Invasion this is not an invasion it's
not a caravan of people like Donald
Trump said he created the word it which
by the way Caravan was created and I
looked this up last night from the late
16th century it comes from Oh I thought
it was like a Dodge Mopar thing
I love to have a word I've got a
caravan we've had several we've had
several Caravans at our house yeah we
didn't like put aob anything many to
many years of my childhood my friends
having Dodge Caravans the redesigned
Caravan the new they got the stow and go
man you put a lot of [__] in there it's
just one of those like a lot of drugs
you can put a lot of drugs a lot of lot
of lot of illegal drugs in
there but when when you've got them
talking about how it's an invasion you
also have to understand that there's one
you don't have a bunch of migrants
coming over the border and saying we're
going to steal this territory because
that's what an invasion is you have a
group of people coming over with Force
trying to steal territory typically with
uh with weapons I'm sorry have we seen
anyone try to cross the border with weap
weapons with Force killing people saying
we're going to take our land back which
by the way uh we got to remember that
America stole the land from Mexico just
putting it out
there easy on the fact easy on the fact
I'm not I'm not saying I'm not saying
that this is an action that's Justified
to come back and do that but what I am
saying is there is no Invasion when you
have innocent innocent mothers innocent
children in breaking news gab chanes
calls for war for Mexico to take their
country back I'm saying if there was
ever what I will say what I will say is
I'm not saying that's what should happen
but I mean if there was ever a group of
people who were justified in the acts of
having an invasion on their own
land maybe you know you reap what you
sow well let's listen to let's listen to
Gavin Newsome how he put it this morning
and get Gabe Sanchez out of the
situation where he's calling for Mexico
to declare war
war Mitch mccon I thought that was
shameful what was reported out that he
just completely rolled over and
capitulating don't even get me started
with the weakness of the current Speaker
of the House I mean they don't want to
deal period full stop they don't want to
deal they don't want to make this quote
unquote campaign win for Joe Biden it
says everything you need to know about
the fraud that they're perpetuating on
the issue of the Border they want to
make this a political issue consistently
they have wanted to make it ever since
there were a few brave souls with that
gang of eight if we all remember those
black and white movie I'm old enough to
remember that and ever since there
everyone they just walk away they run
away the first day he was in office not
not the next day the same day he gets
sworn in he puts out a comprehensive
immigration plan that was and yet you
didn't have a counter they had no
strategy in terms of of the Republican
Party even even combating that they just
wanted to kill it they didn't want to
debate it they didn't want to engage 14
billion dollar proposal 14 billion
dollar that's his latest proposal to
address their stated issue of border
security 2300 new border patrol agents
another thousand in addition to that to
deal with fenol close to another billion
dollars $850 plus billion dollars just
for new technology and then address some
of the issues of backlog on Asylum to
address those that are here waiting okay
I want to say this this di dve here it
is so good I wish he would add in the
dark Brandon economy and the dark
Brandon border that is exactly what we
need as far as messaging is gav new
being like look how could you not want
all this stuff and it would deliver a
dark brand in economy that has been
delivered by dark Brandon and the
economy is rolling baby it's rolling
along it's rolling and we can roll along
with the dark Brandon border too we can
do it dark Brandon can do it with the
economy and he can do it with the Border
this guy's great with messaging I don't
care what you think about California how
he is as a governor um this guy is great
at messing I gotta say I I think he's I
think Gavin usum does a phenomenal job
he was also the
person that if we remember in November
called out the the fact that Ronda
santis was going to bend the knee for
Donald Trump he was going to endorse the
guy in a matter of weeks and you know it
took to the new year so it was like
really like two months L than two months
right that's weeks that's we weeks
that's weeks and you that weeks and then
GA and then Gavin new was like oh boy
fire sale on the Ronda santis merch
today damn he's great at mockery too
he's great at mockery he sure is but you
know what you know who we can mock over
and over and over time and time again
from our list of Bon heads this week the
winner of the bonehead of the week
Governor Greg Abbott the roller Nazi gab
Sanchez let's give him his
[Music]
[Applause]
due
[Music]
oh yeah you [__] fascist you cousin
[__] I want to point out Matt Gates was
like two 2% on one and like six% on the
other are you
serious and I think you know why I think
it's because that news broke and it was
kind of washed over by the border stuff
right right it's washed over by manga
wanting wanting to go to war with the
United States of America that that that
thing where Donald Trump's like Oh no
you're not take a deal and we're going
to go to war we're going to go to war
with the United States I'm not
treasonist I just want to go to war with
the United States
okay many people are saying okay okay
excuse me excuse me very rude okay I'm
the only people crossing the border
should be white
people that is definitely how he
feels about this hey hang on one second
transition to the r regular stuff there
we go we're back to the
boom so I I I don't have time to play
the music because I gotta go get my
tattoo I gota get my tattoo did you hear
about this thing no is that the is this
your first tattoo or is that boom my
very first tattoo it's going on my arm
now this is this is the inspiration
Design This is the merch design this
machine kills fascist but yes I'm
getting a tattoo of a microphone right
here today and it's going to say this
machine kills fascist on it and I'm
going to get the Statue of Liberty
eventually over here and then some stuff
on my upper arm so it's a whole sleeve
it's a whole sleeve sleeve right but the
first part is the microphone today and
I'm driving almost two hours well a
little over two hours to get it artist
up by Kansas City oh okay by Kansas City
Missouri so how long is it multiple
sessions are gonna be yes this one is a
4 hour and then um I'll probably do
another three maybe four four hours
probably so so Pro and then um it's
gonna be a whole thing um so but I do
want to thank everyone who gave to the
team tattoo fund let me show you that
here here's the team tattoo fund that we
did so everyone contributed all this
money goes to the artist every single
nickel of it goes to the artist wow you
guys went way over and above the the
[__] goal here this morning we're
like $40 away from it so thank you very
much to everyone who gave I'm gonna have
toct you got remember to remember to
lather up with um yeah
um with aquafor yeah that's the best
yeah that's that's we we've got some
because my wife has had several tattoos
so she so she's got an aqua for and she
uses it so I I'll be doing that but but
I I got to get going at the top of the
hour I cannot waste any more time but
Gabe Sanchez tell us where they can all
find you tell us so of course you can
find me at
youtube.com IAM gab Sanchez you can find
me on patreon because as you know I am a
oneman show I do it all myself film WR
edit all that stuff so patreon.com
Sanchez you can also become a member and
support me over on YouTube as well you
can just click the join button there um
but yeah you're doing your show your
show is Tuesday Wednesday Thursday what
time Tuesday Wednesday Thursday 5:00 P
PM Pacific 8:00 pm Eastern boom I was
there last night when you started I I
saw you in got the notification and I um
and I was talking about Alina habas dsls
H you were you were it was the only
thing on your mind got the dsls on my
mind I was you get a tattoo of like a
little kiss Mar and be like that's Elena
kissing my ass kiss my ass
[__] you have a great weekend everyone
else have a great weekend again team
tattoo if you contributed I'm G to grab
your email and we're gonna go and I'm
gonna send you an email you're going to
get an email here really soon I promise
with all the links so don't forget to
click those links and save them so you
get notifications and you go to the
patreon how you get to the patreon for
these announcements here's how you do it
you go to the Tony michaels.com you go
to the Tony and you join for free then
cost you a single nickel to join the
patreon because that's where I'm going
to announce 10 or 15 minutes before I
stream because you on team tattoo who
contributed you're going to get access
to the live stream you're going to get
access to these links and I'll be
announcing it on patreon but you're
going to want to make sure to open your
email and click those links and set up
the notifications for those particular
live streams you're going to want to do
that there's five of them we're probably
gonna we're probably going to do four
we're definitely going to do four we
might do five I got a Bonus one just in
case you know how [__] technical
things are you know I can get all right
Gabe Sanchez
youtube.com gab Sanchez go to the Tony
michaels.com get your Ted Cruz merch get
your tattoo merch join team tattoo we
got we're gonna see you here in a bit on
a private listing on the tubes of you on
the tubes of you so
everyone until Monday same time same
place Surfs Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's meor head ass
speaking some neighbors are saying way
too loud that's only in the morning you
supposed to be up cooking breakfast or
somebody and so that's like a alarm
clock
w